gelli thierry pas une visant neuf mois à
la bise direct gélade colati merci ça
l'a alors à toi toi tu es boue tout
autour c'est ce qu'il y ait encore
connue oui mais alors non oui bah moi
excusez moi parce que la gare camille tu
remarqueras c'est le seul mec il a amené
une clim pour lui refroidir le le le
c'est ce qu'on demande avoir une clim
non c'est pas moi il avait sauté du
froid était ouvert la porte il ya le mec
quoi il donne je l'avais une toute
petite porte est donc un moyen plus
beaux de froid comme merci comment savez
vous quand vous allez les contente
orageux découvert une appli égard quoi
connaissez fayçal si vous prenez le en
font mais le visage de quelqu'un et on
voit ce qui donnerait s'il était du sexe
opposé jalsa qui avait bouder ce soir
j'aurais rêvé de voir bouder ans mais je
n'ai en plus à vous je je n'ai pas le
goût des grands matches défaite je vous
allez voir à quoi vous ressemblez dans
le sexe opposé la doua gilles verdez bio
gilou regardez ça qui est très à son
avantage en inde
patrice et pas dans des débats seraient
tentés moi mais ça rigolait il est
beaucoup mieux comme ça versez feriez
une très belle à 9 sur ya une très belle
femme à la barre l'homme en a bavé ça
s'est joué à attritionnel aulas castaldi
belle elle me rappelle un film
jvh est-ce que généreux non mais
franchement vous n'êtes pas malgré son
énorme enfants faites vous les voiries
zahawi en oeuvre en neuf
isaure on s'est rendu compte c'est que
lisa en sommes
bartabas et alain son mari en tête des
courses et la suisse attend quoi c'est
plus martin lamotte oui de quoi dans vos
femmes et aimé à cause de la mode dont
vous êtes vous êtes beaucoup plus belle
en femme est ravie s'est heureusement
heureusement isabelle luc lemoine il est
pas là son jeu pour faire juger avec le
moins bon et les méchants lui que moi
dans ma magnifique mais j'ai valérie
benaïm en sommes regardés
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je sais a pris la mer mercredi
non non je sais que je m'excuse et les
photos que marcher avec la jeunesse
qu'usagers la photo originale mais s'est
passé il ya des photos ça marche pas
trouvé génial qu'on a trouvé bien y en a
d'autres et vous vous envolez g qui lie
en sommes
non abbas est bien elle est toujours
fraîche pas mon délire mais un délit
ringer hanouna en femme
une enfant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non j'ai pas fait chez elle par ses
adjoints
[Applaudissements]
parce que je pourrais me pécho ouais
c'est vrai et c'est les morts maintenant
vous êtes n'ayant pas ma tête tout au
début en forme
ouais il va trouver quelques des femmes
finalement à xalapa agathe nasa exemple
j'ai pas joué les gars je pense faire
prendre pour 2010 mais j'ai un petit
truc pour vous adapter à ces chalets
aujourd'hui ce chalet sur vos story 1
star j'ai trouvé quelques petites choses
j'ai une quatre voies d'une choucroute
et les 24 heures de tv moi tu peux juste
laquelle zone de la mer
ce qu'il fallait absolument pas rater
heure par heure au cours de ces
dernières 24 heures regardez thema hier
soir à 23h30 j'ai regardé le replay de
slam et cyril féraud a posé une question
il s'est pris de réponse dans les
gencives direct je suis né au québec
j'ai vécu avec 9 1 1 là bas et je suis
en france depuis six ans dans le gers et
comment on passe du québec au gers avec
l'avion
celle de france 2 mais les journalistes
ont de plus en plus de mal à retrouver
leurs mots on revient en france on
certains conducteurs pour le clos où le
cours de se demander que l'on retrouve
en direct le cauterets dans les
hautes-pyrénées bonjour lisa p à 15h30
apparemment le bonhomme cetelem a pas
rendu l'oseille qui devait à ses gars
mon pote dans taratata regarder yanagi
qu aurait peut-être dû donner son rose
pas dû donner par dans son ressenti sur
le dernier type de charlotte gainsbourg
qui sont présents aussi d'ailleurs si on
est patient jusqu'à la fin de l'album on
peut entendre quelques quelques enfants
qui chantent une enfant qui chante dans
une image in mois autant certains se
voulait exclure dans les images des
répètes de kenny pour le prochain prime
ne touche pas à mon poste ça s'annonce
canon beaucoup de courrier pour nous
demander ce que fait cyril avant
l'émission et bas comme monsieur tout le
monde
il va dans un fast food et bois des
verts avec ses potes
[Applaudissements]
un jour ça à partir de tiger woods
l'homme aux pas rester le cul vi ait
chasse bat regarder à rigaud est la
soirée chez regarder les jt aussi parce
que l'événement de ce début de semaine
c'est quoi c'est l'ouverture du salon de
l'agriculture
tout le monde que c'est le même expert
en plateau pour parler des
revendications des agriculteurs et bfm
ils ont trouvé celui qui est imbattable
l'huile est rabattable pour parler
agriculture de la journée des manuels
macron salon de l'agriculture et on va
la décrypter cette journée avec nos
invités sur le plateau de marc dufumier
bonjour
le record de présence au salon il est
resté 12h30 et en 12h30 est temps de
faire connaissance avec tout le monde
mario rick notamment une limousine à
qu'il a bien accroché de viande bovine
venant de pays étrangers car il nous
explique que c'est bon surprise même l'a
dit nabila a passé une tête au salon ça
s'est bien passé bon jusqu'au drame et
enfin le fmi ils ont reçu quelqu'un
qu'on connaît bien liane de catherine et
liliane qui lance visiblement sa
carrière solo
je parle pas comme dans un bonbon sucré
bien sûr ça marche de la dictature
c'est la nouvelle à une amende si c'est
vrai hélas je fouille des très drôle
celui-ci j'ai regardé les ch'tis et anti
me faut merci à regarder je trouverais
j'ai gardé je prends ça y est j'ai
regardé je prends voilà rien mais
plusieurs tentatives en vain de gagner
des chiffres et des lettres
je suis pas fâché je continue de
regarder tous les jours france 3 en ce
moment dans questions pour un champion
il ya un truc qui se passe samuel
etienne ne reçoit que des candidats
poids ça c'est quoi la guigne et jaya
benoît écrit le plus jour à une lettre
près d'avoir la bonne réponse c'est
quand vous avez la bonne réponse je
l'avais il ya une lettre qui va pas
c'est passé à ça de sa mère à chaque
fois dynastique un peu trop en
gymnastique rythmique avec l accessoire
long et les deux mois le turban le ruban
blanc qu'elle n'emportait le berger ou
noir farouk mabrouk gorée dans un autre
registre il est pas mal aussi à giggs et
ensuite seulement il se demande s'il a
la bonne réponse est trop tard 48 et la
libération à travailler grégory sur la
préfabrication des formules nh3 a été
grégory encore non entre les affections
à les briques de lait
grégory toujours pas et enfin c'est
assez rare sur france 3 on a vu la
naissance de deux futurs candidats
potentiels pour les changes
il était dans huit chansons que gagner
je vous demande s'il vous plaît de citer
des oeuvres de gustave flaubert a passé
cinq secondes à la bouille le père
goriot le père mourir taxi driver le
café les marseillais voit l'image du
matador il m'a toujours sans déconner
attention pour passer un instant - de
dar k gemayel ça y est nous y tu es dans
l'édition du 13 heures devinez qui on a
vu poser paix pouce au calme aux côtés
du chef marc veyrat
regardez c'est qui l'acteur franck
gastambide qui cherchent les bons coins
à champignons on vers l'est aussi la
taxe et 515 dédie à ma lutte avec vous
j'ai zappé sur le jt de jean pierre
pernaut la base est à mon avis la main à
plat de lasagnes coincé dans la bouche
ce matin galère et jean piat et les
risques d'avalanche chanteur maximum
avec leur douche les dernières semaines
et de l'étape 4 à strophes naturel eh
oui si elles sont un quatrième quart
d'anachronismes la tradition là bas avec
les parades et déguisements sur le tgv
en abonnant donc les petites lignes
peloton parti noté compartimenté
au fait j'ai bientôt et pendant un sujet
si quelqu'un peut m'expliquer ce que
fait ce chien là ça choque peut-être que
moi merci de nous écrire quand des
allemands à vous et attention après
trente ans de jt jean pierre pernaut
aurait décidé de casser les codes et de
par les tricheurs pour rajeunir son
trésor même à un autre sujet à propos
d'une mode c'est le grand retour cette
année
alors de quoi partie de la tendance des
tisseurs l'oversize le retour du tie and
dye grand retour cette année des bonnet
à pompon
je perds la pop vient toucher tombe on
se met plus à une escalade escalade
je vais pas là des spasmes ameloot est
en train de toucher les pays encore
c'est déjà bien et tacle un bisou c'est
bien voilà ça y est comme ma soeur
isabelle encore akwaba oui mais pas
encore pour y dormir de tous les deux se
passera rien ah ben ça c'est sûr mais
c'est sur wii on va faire un jeu créé
dit à mes questions si les parties de
hockey il ya deux choix à chaque fois
attention train ou avion avions avions
eu j louisa les argiles tf1 ou m6 tf1 m6
j'arrête la chronique outre aucune la
chronique quoique tu continues à genoux
ouais mais en fait j'ai dit une fois ce
que je préférais une fois que ce jeu de
mots - 1 contre zilina je ne sais pas en
fait nous et entre tf1 m6 annonce même
si moi je veux le plus gros beats de
2018 mais bien plus gros bide sur le
plateau de la quotidienne de france 5 il
ya un chroniqueur de la bande et c'est
mignon il tente une blague mais là on a
affaire à un bidon niveau iv en ressenti
niveau 6
à côté jean mi c'est gad elmaleh
franchement regardez savez bien il faut
être
ce que les cinq premiers qui vont nous
envoyer le mot attention marquis
recevoir le coffret ses marques québon
techniques gênants ce qu'on aime dans la
quotidienne c'est la proximité entre les
chroniques empociello tu sens qu'il
s'apprécie ne se connaissent par coeur
les uns les autres toute la série des
alors il va il va être content
l'espagnol puisque ça c'est surtout
d'ailleurs dans la rédac de la
quotidienne du jeune journaliste qui
devrait vous plaire cyril vu son nom à
mon avis rien à lire chez nous celle là
alors quelle est la différence entre ces
deux produits vous allez voir que
parfois payant n'a aucune star reportage
de lola pamiers avec lucas negri et
pauline au smic sur france 3 hier sinon
muriel robin était dans l'émission sur
la terre rouge à boire à la découverte
des grands mammifères dans leur élément
naturel et c'est vrai que les images
étaient était d'un gain après quatre
heures de cache cache avec nous
souverain sur son territoire il vient de
décider
il était temps que nos chemins se
croisent enfants
simon
là
les rendez-vous qui marque beaucoup plus
loin que tout ça c'est le plus gros
jamais drôle de france et mais moi j'ai
bien aimé ses marques et mon kiki
j'ai bien aimé la vase sortez pas de
chez vous sur abc mois dont 8 ferme
tim hunkin a on a beaucoup non non on
est en dessous ah oui au fait qu'on ait
choisi les 18 trous de sa maman platz où
un rabbin presqu'île du trou du cul
ouais voilà voulait lancer les
encourager roddick s'est qualifié à
markit
et moi ça tourne à ce sujet
or végétation avec siri un truc qu'on
tolère pas c'est l'arrogance
je me défends laisse tout passer mais
pas l'arrogance c'est votre là c'est
votre passage chez votre chez-vous kg
girerd ce matin j'ai croisé un pote g10
à lui patrick comment tu vas ça va super
ça fait hyper longtemps comme on ta
femme et tes gosses bien je te remercie
elle a quitté son boulot à la mairie ça
va ça s'est bien passé ou et ça va super
je te dit tu vas c'est des extraits d'
enquête d'action ce soir chez nous n'a
pas de problème fait lui un bisou passe
le bonjour à baba j'ai donc regardé en
face avec des policiers ont fait une
paire qu'ils l'ont rêvé toute la section
un jour dans un lancement dans un squat
l'ambiance était je vous jure on n'était
pas bien était hypertendues six missions
quand ap sérieux franchement 9
du swing vous noterez kane qui sont
tombées sur les tagueurs les plus polis
de france qui s'inquiète de savoir si
les policiers se porte bien on en a
d'autres oui regardera tous les autres
[Rires]
bien sûr et en appel d'urgence regardés
on était sur une intervention c'est un
accident de la circulation il doit
déterminer les circonstances de
l'accident
oui alors là je pense que la voiture l'a
percuté à mon avis sur w9 et tentent
d'interpeller un malfrat vu son surnom
dont la vie va d'y perdre tout street
crédibilité en prison une aubaine pour
les gendarmes mais ils sont méfiants ce
voleur réfuté extrêmement prudent
isabelle boulay et aux etats unis c'est
sérieux ce que je vais vous montrer et
cherche aussi à interpeller un criminel
mais vu le portrait robot diffusé sur
les chaînes info il peut dormir
tranquille le gars même le journaliste
croit que c'est une balle mais non f150
[Rires]
ils ont été et je vous jure qu'ils
ressemblent dernière petite chose
jb je vous sens tout faux ce sont déjà
dans french suivre sur nrj12 ya sarah
qui a reçu un message vidéo poignant
saucède faya des messages des proches et
tout ça m'a foutu la larmichette c'est
papa
c'est fou parce que tu changes de
messages dans la télé les larmes des
candidats peuvent te paraître encore
plus crédible ils sont terrorisés la
route vous offrira quatre ouvrage
remarquablement illustré retraçant
l'histoire de la guerre à travers des
documents rares c'est passionnant et des
témoignages bouleversants
ouais c'est dur simon donc sur les
réseaux sociaux hier j'ai super peur
agathe a posté une story ça m'a stressé
de dingue
et ce n'est pas bien je suis au bord du
précipice on devait qu'est ce qui a bien
pu lui arriver de si dramatique pour
qu'elle soit obligée d'appeler à l'aide
pour s'en sortir
je n'arrive pas à dire l'amour j'avais
très bien elle a un peu bloqué fall a
tiré hier soir donc si jamais vous
attendent 10 9 en décembre et que vous
allez ouvrir des portes chômage alors on
est remonté plus loin dans les instants
et c'est vrai qu'elle est souvent bord
du précipice pour des choses qui ne
semble pas si compliqué
parce qu'en fait faut appuyer sur des
boutons donc si vous êtes dans le 19e
arrondissement
et puis ça aurait appuyé sur des
bouteilles envoyez moi un message et un
alain melaye ce sont des faits donc si
vous êtes dans le 19e arrondissement
vous savez faire des lacets bon faut des
mois un message sous bout de ma life
quoi le robinet fonctionne pas si vous
êtes dans dix neuvième art martial vous
avez démarré des robinets pas envoyez
moi un message quoi je peux mal à y
faire
et on la porte était dur alors vous avez
trouvé quelqu'un ou pas vous avez trouvé
quelqu'un mais j'ai réussi tout ça c'est
un énorme passe-partout fasciné dans le
19ème crochet ses pattes avons fait avec
ça c'est fort vous quittez j'ai fini
j'en ai à stéphane gentil du moule
[Applaudissements]